Hi, good morning, Wayne.
Good morning.
I didn't realize, I thought, you know, one of my team members...
Virtual assistant joined in, then I saw your name later on. OK, thank you. Well, thank you for finding your time, and...
I'm kind of virtual.
I mean, you already asked in the morning, I mean, you're doing good. So health-wise and otherwise, I think things are moving in good shape.
Sure.
I mean, that was my question in the form of statement.
Right.
Yeah.
Okay, is Jim doing good?
Didn't we just have this meeting?
Yeah.
We had this meeting last month, I mean it comes I mean so quickly.
Wow, that.
The last month went fast.
Yeah, absolutely. It seems, you know, you're going still pretty, pretty busy, which is why I mean, time just flies. It flies by.
Yeah, I don't think Jim is joining this one. I know he's got appointments all day.
Okay. Otherwise, is it doing good? I mean, it's been ages, I would say. I mean, you know, I interacted with Jim. You know, I was thinking one day that probably till last year, up till some months, I mean, he was joining in, but I think, so I, you know, I was thinking since I came to this role, so
But...
Maybe Jim is thinking I'm handling this responsibility very well, and you know he's tough to join. Oh, and he trusts you more that you, Gagan and Alex can, you know, can handle things very well. So he's keeping his focus somewhere else. Thank you, Lee, for joining in.
Good morning.
S.
Absolutely. Hey, Gagan. Hey, Wayne.
Hello.
Right.
Have you met William before?
Probably a while ago. Wayne, do I look familiar? You're off camera, so I can't place a face at the moment, but your name is very familiar.
Okay.
Y.
I, you don't look familiar to me.
Okay, all right. So, pleasure to call you because I can't, like you said, I can't remember if we have just seen your name on a lot of threads or if we've actually been on a call, but it's a pleasure. I actually head up the Dedicated Service, so I work very closely with Gagan, with Vishal, with Sameer.
and team just on this side of the of the ocean. And on based out of our New Jersey office. So just jumping on and say, hey, see how things are going and be a fly on the wall.
All right, so thank you, Lee, for joining in. Pleasure having you and Wayne here on this call. We understand, you know, Jim is mostly busy handling some outside work meetings with the client, Western client side, so we understand. Hi, hi, Andy.
Sounds good.
Thank you for joining, as well.
Hello, thank you. Sorry for the delay. Hello, Wayne. Hello, Lee. Hello, Gagan once again.
Hello!
OK.
Yeah, hello. So thank you once again. Welcome everyone to this call officially. So if you're good to see the presentation, I mean, I can quickly show on my screen really quick. When are we good?
I believe we are.
Please let me know once it's there on your screens.
Das.
All right, thank you. So this is a business review for June. You know, we'll be reviewing Alex's performance for the month of May. And
Nothing much changed in terms of our agenda items. So, what I'll just quickly walk you through, we have highlights, performance, KPI analysis, ITBD CSAT, US holidays schedule, AI by design, ITBD is initiative, a way forward with
Deirdre technologies, and of course, recap, which I set up this call with minutes of meetings.
And I have a habit of saying, I shouldn't be saying this, but please feel free to chime in whatever you think you have any feedback, suggestion or insight or anything. So by discussing these points and hearing from you, we'll be able to understand
Where exactly is that an opportunity for us to fix things or make a little better than before? Thank you.
A few of the highlights that I captured for this period, so Alex depicted consistent improvement in *** documentation. We'll be reviewing this further and...
He consistently met his available target in May as well, and he met his ticket resolved a target as well. So, before we move on, when overall, what are what are your observations?
I think everything is going great.
Recently, we've had him more involved in break-fix type things.
That's been going well.
Yeah.
Yeah, he has been. You know, appreciating that. I mean, for the past few months, you know, he is being added to some distinct tasks other than guardian boards. So that's pretty impressive. And this is exactly what he always was inclined towards. He wanted to have something more on his plate.
to be added. So thank you for listening to Alex. I mean, to give him some tasks that I mean, he can he could satisfy his hunger, you know, towards those technological things.
Moving on to performance analysis. Okay, first one, you know, as per Jim's demand, so this is SOPs, what he's creating. So I'm assuring for the last five months, you know, because this is exactly what Jim would like to see.
So we see that consistently has been going. I mean, we see a little, you know, drop in April, but he again picked it up in the month of May. He worked on 10 recipes.
And, uh, you know, spend, uh, in a good time, uh, 3.83 hours on it.
So this is exactly what my emphasis on. I know as we discussed last time, this is not a P1, but we can consider this P2, but still, that's an important activity. So when I speak to him, he says, yeah, most of the SOPs that he has to.
work on, I mean, in terms of tickets that is sending on garden boards. So most of them, he believes, have been updated.
But still, as you know, some change he finds out needs to be added in those SOPs, so he picks up and make the changes according to you. Any views on this, Wayne?
No.
Making you satisfied to some extent.
Absolutely.
All right, thank you. Nice to hear from you. Moving on to utilization trends. Yeah, this month he had...
Three time ups on the 19th, he had sick leave. He was out sick on 25th, there was ITBD holiday, US holiday. And on the 26th, I mean, he wanted to have extended time with his family. So he had, so thank you. I really do appreciate you approved his leave for 26th. And
So with this extended time, he was able to spend some good time with his family at travel time to his in-laws. But that ultimately did have some impact on the number of tickets that he worked on. But he still was able to meet his available target.
You know, as we decided previously, that is a 70%. So he achieved 73.24 and non-billable remained 26.76%.
Yeah, so in the week where he has been consistent, I mean, every week, you know, going above 70%, so seventy-three in the first week, then seventy-three again, seventy-four, seventy-three.
I...
As Pre.
These are fine.
Okay, thank you.
Moving on to, I think it was already, so yeah, there you see, you know, there's a...
To drop it, so I document a few, you know, insights from my end while I was speaking to Alex, he said there are few points, there was less you got in alerts in flow during this this period. Second thing, he was out one day in.
in the third week, which is for May 18th to 19th, and two days it was out on in May 25th to 29th. And thirdly, he said, there are...
Two more team members, Dustin and Mac, I believe.
Max, yeah, he was an intern and he's not here anymore.
Max, OK.
Okay, so Alex said, so they were also contributing their efforts in the, you know, on the guiding board, so which is why you know some of the tickets got, you know, aligned to them as well. They were also working on a guiding board, so which is why you might you are observing this.
Drop in the tickets.
Yeah, I think he might have been working some more complex tickets, too. You know, if a ticket only takes you a minute, you can do 60 of them in an hour. But if it takes an hour, you can only get one ticket done.
Any other?
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Yeah, absolutely, because we see numbers in comparison to April. He was touching close to 199, which is close to 100, almost 100 or 100 plus, 139, 140 in second week and 4th week. But those were purely guiding alerts, which he is able to.
complete within 3 to 4 minutes max. But yeah, you're right. If he's working on a break fix ticket.
It may take 20, 25, or 30 minutes, which means it will, it does take, you know, time of 10 tickets, you know, just one very quick ticket.
But I'm glad that his ticket resolve rate, you know, still did not impact. So he was able to complete those tickets same day, most of them, and his ticket resolve rate numbers to 79%, which is close to 80. Then for the remaining weeks, 86, 87, and 83%. So
So that's going good as for me, but if you think something else he needs attention on, I'll be glad to hear from you.
No, these are fine.
Ben.
Okay. Thank you, Wayne. And I really do appreciate for encouraging Alex for all what he does in your environment by giving him a positive CSAT for the month of May as well. I truly appreciate that.
And yeah, as we discussed already, so his upcoming, I mean, apart from compass, which you already know, must be marked on your calendar already, his upcoming one of the, after one of the five options, so he has selected.
the sharer that was shared previously as well. So, but we will still confirm that with you once the date is near, at least two weeks in advance.
However...
If you think there's any sort of business special business requirement on that special specific day, you can let us know and we can speak to Alex if you can accommodate and cover shift, you know, on that specific day and take a complimentary off later on.
Sure.
Now, I pass gives the stage to Andy.
Thank you. Thank you, Gagan. When we discussed earlier also, as we have our Build It event in August 3rd to 5th, and do you have any thoughts about it? Would you like to know more as if you can send somebody or if you can visit?
Our event, that's an educational and training event.
I don't think we're gonna have anybody available this year.
Because I had a word with Jim also and I'm following up with him also. So that's why I just briefly asked you.
Yeah, if anybody goes, it would probably be him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, right. And Lee, any thoughts on your side?
I believe Jim has also registered for a AI accelerator, the upcoming one, I believe.
He did attend 1AX later in around fall last year. Virtual, that was virtual, yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, October last year, yeah.
Yeah, I don't see him on the list for a build at this time around. We'll reach out to him, you know, directly if, if, if that's the path to take to double check in. Wayne, I know it's probably difficult to pull away, but I will say the event is is...
Right.
Definitely a better one than most industry events I've ever been to. Lots of tangible walkaways, intentionally smaller crowds, so the conversations are meant to be more meaningful, and then we don't really let our...
our breakout sessions pitch, right? The goal of them is really true training sessions, not 35, 45 minute sounds pitches. So definitely meaningfully different. But yeah, we'll reach out to
To do the see what of interest he what kind of interest he's got.
All right, thank you, Andy. Thank you, Lee, for coming this up.
So Jim already knows most of these pieces already, so he has attended the AI accelerator. I believe I just need to double check. I believe he has, you know, registered, you know, in the upcoming AI accelerator as well. But I'll just confirm.
Wayne is going busy, I understand, but Wayne, we would love to, you know, you to, you know, attend these sessions as well, and I'm sure you will like it.
Kip.
And TGPS, you're already aware, so this is a homegrown tool. So whenever you have 30 minutes in order to incorporate these features, include these features in your environment, so you can schedule a demo.
The team, and they'll be glad to give the insight what the tool does and how this can add value at Deirdre Technologies. Yeah.
Lastly, but not the least, way forward.
With technologies, so my focus is continuous for Alex to, you know, strengthen your environment with with more efficient documentation in terms of creating SOPs and support him.
In all sort of tasks that he's getting, especially new tasks that you're adding, break, fix, or any kind of project tasks, if he needs any assistance. So he works in our office with, you know, other experts who sit beside him, and they can assist Stratix if he's stuck on anything.
So please feel free to assign him more challenging tasks. Yeah, you can put on his plate.
And yeah, so June is ending this quarter, Q2. So we're on the verge of moving towards Q3. So our Q3 dineout activity is still pending. So most probably they'll be nearly weekend of 22nd.
27th, I believe that is on 27th. So we are planning outing with our team on 27th or 28th. I'll share the picture with you, you know, how we did this time.
Kip.
Yeah, these, you know, actors play a pivotal role, you know, in terms of spending good time with with our.
Office family, they feel like they're working not just with, you know, professional, strict environment where they always need their numbers, keepers, and everything. They feel like, I mean, they can share, you know, with us, you know, be it, you know, something.
You know, hampering their performance due to some personal challenges or anything, so they open up, they feel, you know, team is may assist or help them in those things as well, so this, I think this is very, very important, and your ITBD at ITBD, we really do.
see value in having these engagements. Thank you.
That is completely all from my end. I believe that's the last slide. Yeah, thank you. Let me unshare my screen.
Wayne, anything that I probably missed out in these slides and should be here.
No.
You're a man of a few words always, but I still, you know, I don't get much time to interact with you, but I still admire your witty sense of humor most of the times. Please add me to your happy hour sometimes. You know, you can send me an invite and, you know, I would like to be a part of that. If you still play.
Bingo or...
Poniatch, I leave.
Yeah, we've done many different games over the years.
OK, so, yeah, thank you. So, you treat me, although I'm not working directly technically with with Deirdre, but you know, I'm working at a backdrop, but still consider me a part of your team and you know, add me to each of those happy hours. I'll be, I'll be...
We'll do that.
Really happy and happy to meet you, the rest of the people as well, Billy Joe, Gary, and yeah, who are still in your environment, yeah.
So that is it, Wayne. Thank you. Andy, Lee, anything else from your end?
Sounds great.
Just wanted to thank Wayne for his time.
Have a good rest of the day.
Yeah, nothing at this show for me, but Wayne, pleasure to meet you, and hope all hope all remains well. Thanks for the feedback and the partnership.
Thanks, Jerome.
Talk to you next time.
Thank you, Wayne. So yeah, thank you everyone. Thank you for joining in. We shall meet next time next month with some more positive updates. Until then, have a great day.
Take care, bye bye.
Sure.